well you know it was it I thought a lot
about what who I would put in the book
and what stories I would follow there
were several obvious characters such as
the Nasr family a Christian family whom
I got to know from 2002 when I first
went to Iraq right up to the time that I
left and I'm alpha dairy was an art
gallery owner these were people that I
had become very good friends with and I
spent a lot of time with so it was easy
to track what had happened to their
lives I'd seen it intimately there were
also several other characters that I
wanted included I tried to make sure
that everyone was represented you know
that I had so many characters in my book
and Shia characters because so much of
what has happened in Iraq really depends
on who you ask people have different
opinions and their experience of the US
invasion and the aftermath is different
based on you know what sectarian line
they fall under so the book has a story
of two young shia clerics that I
befriended after the invasion who
quickly rose to the top of the Shia
hierarchy and two prominent positions
and also some songs are so nice arse
only staff and Sunni tribal leaders so I
really tried to pick you know characters
who were really representative of Iraqis
and the experience that they were going
through
you